inside court number one of the Old
Bailey without doubt the nation's most
high-profile courtroom the scene of many
infamous trials like Ruth Ellis the last
woman to be hanged the gangster Kray
twins former Liberal leader Jeremy
Thorpe and Peter Sutcliffe the auction
Ripper now within months this courtroom
will make history again as television
cameras will for the first time be able
to cover part of the trial process over
the years right here in these press
benches covering many major trials in
this court scribbling down often
dramatic testimony but the lack of
cameras in this courtroom means you're
reliant on me and other correspondents
trying to really a sense of that drama
to you afterwards from outside court no
broadcasters will be able to request
cameras are allowed here at the Old
Bailey and at other major trials to film
the conclusion of those cases as judges
sentence offenders what I hope will
happen is that in high-profile cases
broadcasters such as Sky will use
extracts from the sentencing remarks to
illustrate the news stories that they're
broadcasting so that people will
understand better why the result was as
it is cameras were allowed into the
Supreme Court and the court of appeals
several years ago their introduction has
been judged a success and helped
strengthen the campaign by the main news
broadcasters to include major criminal
trials all the broadcaster's have been
campaigning for cameras in crown courts
for at least 10 years this is a big leap
forward I hope it's successful because
it will open up the courts to greater
transparency and I hope because of that
people think we should extend this to
other courts as well it was snatched
photographs of the infamous dr. Crippen
during his Old Bailey trial for martyr
in 1910 that led to the ban on cameras
in court more than a century later some
of the inner workings of the trial
process
will now be seen again the cameras will
be focused right here on the trial judge
no lawyers defendants or witnesses
initially providing there's a successful
conviction what we'll get is the judges
sentencing remarks in the US the
televised trials of OJ Simpson and later
the British nanny Louise Woodward
attracted huge audiences around the
world as every excruciating detail was
played out before the cameras and that
worries those within the legal
profession here anxious the proceedings
in this country should not become a
spectator sport well I think when you're
talking about the most serious criminal
cases where there's a lot of sensitivity
around the victims rights it is
important to just take one step at a
time this is a really important first
step of course it will be kept under
review in the future but it is important
just to strike that balance between
openness and access on the one hand and
the rights of the victims on the other
so in effect UK broadcasters are
themselves on trial
only when the judiciary is satisfied
that the introduction of cameras here
has been handled responsibly will there
be any consideration to allowing some
other aspects of the trial process to be
filmed mark white Sky News caught one at
the Old Bailey